are the Comming Corp fans last weekend
Faker got booed now there's two
questions here first of all why would
anyone boo Faker and second of all do
orts fans maybe need to lighten up let's
answer them
both so last weekend League of Legends
fans were treated to the Red Bull League
of its own event which brought fresh
world champions T1 to Europe for a
series of exhibition matches zos Ona
Faker Gushi and krier took place in a
number of show match games facing off in
best of ones against six European teams
the European teams were made up of G2
and team Heretics from the LEC French
favorites carine core from the EMA
German erl squads big and inra Spandau
as well as streamer team n andno old
even with T1 being jet lagged and still
recovering from Worlds last month they
comfortably eliminated one team after
another in front of the 7,000 strong
Berlin crowd despite their handicap of
not being able to select Champions they
played in previous matches except in the
final he is still figuring this champ
out I feel
dros the backside go four man Al Carri a
cleaning house now they did end up
losing the final versus G2 which was a
little bit of an upset I would say but
it was undoubtedly one of the most
entertaining days in the league of
Legends calendar this year now normally
you would expect the final of a
tournament like this to be the one that
Drew the most viewership but that's not
what happened here while T's game
against G2 pulled in over 370,000
viewers it was their match versus caring
core that attracted the event Peak
viewership of almost half a million
people Kor have become a big name in
League of Legends in recent years
despite being a tier 2 Team their
support dwars that of most LEC orgs in
fact whatever the esport their fans turn
up in numbers to support them and
they're really [__] loud in a rocket
league tournament this year they more
closely resembled European football fans
than traditional Esports fans as we can
see the hype the KC flags are already
out this is even a KC matchup dorf is
definitely going to be going crazier and
crazier as the day continues so it
wasn't really a surprise that they'd
Make some noise for their league team
when T1 came to town last weekend but
some of the noise they were making
raised a few
eyebrows
that's so sad you can't Boo the goat
some people were outraged on Twitter
calling out the KC fans for booing Faker
during the pre-tournament interview
there was a general sense of confusion
as to why anyone would Boo the League of
Legends goat and some Kor fans were Keen
to remind everyone that it wasn't all of
them that did this and to not paint the
entire fan base with the same brush Kam
the French streamer and founder of Kor
defended the orgs fans on Twitter too
saying saying that some fans made a
mistake and that they condemned that he
added that no one in T1 even cared about
it based on a conversation with T1 coo
this was a sentiment echoed by Kore CEO
who said they never encouraged their
fans to boo that the majority of fans
were quick to silence those who did Boo
and that their fans are more connected
to traditional Sports atmospheres than
what Esports fans are used to now first
off it's important to remember that this
kind of booing is probably nothing
personal against Faker he's simply the
final boss of League of Legends that had
arrived on the scene to take down the
team that these kcore fans support it's
that simple but the real question at the
heart of all of this has been did those
fans cross a line by booing Faker the
answer is of course subjective those who
say it's fine have often pointed to
traditional Sports where any member of
an opposing team is taunted at every
opportunity and this is particularly
true in European sporting culture if you
told a European sporting fan that you
could hear hear some booze in the
background of a player's interview they
would probably wonder what the big
problem is booing might not be
celebrated or encouraged but it's
certainly not unexpected so the question
is should it be the same in Esports and
honestly only you can answer that for me
do I think it's nice to boo Faker No not
particularly do I think the fans should
be chastised and would I demand that
they show respect to him probably not
there's a sense among some people that
Esports needs a bit more of a kick to it
perhaps Esports fans need a little
thicker skin perhaps they should be a
bit meaner to their opposition Esports
fans have always had this perception of
being a little soft around the edges
they don't boo they don't chant they
don't beat their chest they don't have a
strong dislike for their Rivals maybe
they don't even support a single team on
the one hand this helps Esports to feel
approachable and inclusive it keeps it
PG it keeps it family and marketing
friendly it keeps the events feeling fun
and light-hearted and these are some of
the traits that have helped the Esports
industry explode in popularity over the
past decade but it's resulted in tens of
millions of fans that might be
passionate about their scene but are
largely indifferent to individual teams
they might own A team's shirt until
their favorite player leaves they might
go to an event purely for the experience
and have a good time regardless of who
wins obviously all of this is absolutely
fine and it's the Normy sports but it
couldn't be more different to
traditional Sports where this kind of
booing comes from I think where people
are fanatically devoted to a team for
life and have a real lifelong dislike
for their Rivals and this deep rooted
loyalty can translate well over to
consistent ticket and merchandise sales
as well as media subscriptions would
that kind of reliability and stability
from a fan base help the Esports
industry in an era where they're
struggling to monetize their tens of
millions of fans maybe this is obviously
just a theory and only one aspect of a
much larger and more complex problem but
what happened over the weekend makes it
a good time to bring this kind of stuff
up up now the side effect of more Fierce
passionate and intense loyalty from
Esports fans would of course be a bit
more banter perhaps some more Trash Talk
directed at teams and individual players
and maybe even a few more Boos obviously
nobody is saying booing will save eorts
or that booing is inherently a good
thing but it has raised some interesting
questions was it nice to boo Faker No
even carine cor's owner has condemned it
but should fans be scolded if they do
decide to boo as an Esports fan that's
up for you to decide I think for me
coming from English football that's a
bit strange because this whole
conversation around booing Faker is so
mild that wouldn't even make the
headlines in England that wouldn't even
be a tweet you know if you tweeted out
can't believe that player got like
people be like what what are you talking
about that's just that's that's just
called a Wednesday yeah